herzlich willkommen wieder an dem ort wo
sich das niveau ca auf höhe des erdkerns
befindet richtig meine lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
neuen video auf meinem kanal ihr seht es
bereits im titel eingeblendet wir machen
heute mal wieder e-mails bzw machen wir
keine sondern ich zeig euch welche und
das hier ist direkt der erste überfall
und zwar verkauft dort jemand einen
gaming pc allerdings nicht den pc
sondern den zusammenbau die aufrüstung
und mehr und ein potenzieller käufer
schreibt pc noch da fragezeichen da es
allerdings um keinen pc geht antwortet
der verkäufer darauf hin wenn sie
richtig lesen würden wüssten sie dass
kein pc zum verkauf stehen ich war auf
sonderschule ich will nicht lesen
das ist dann ihr problem alles klappt
auch geil einen tag vor meinem
geburtstag wurde das ganze über
nächstenliebe fällen geht es um eine
super preis verhandlungsstrategie die
dort verfolgt wird und zwar schreibt ein
potenzieller käufer also ein interessent
von dem verkauften produkte 300 euro
fragezeichen
schick der telefonnummer dazu der
verkäufer antwortet 1150 euro 250 euro
[Musik]
das hier ist das nächste produkt das auf
ebay kleider zeigen angeboten wird man
denkt jetzt vielleicht wenn man sich das
produkt erst mal anschaut hey das ist
ein altes holz kunstwerk keine ahnung
was geschnitzt worden im watt bei sich
die vierte jahrhundert hinein
das ist eine originelle antik stuhl
ja ich brauche keinen stuhl ich kann
einfach so in meine ecken kommen nun
allerdings wieder zu rosen sind rot
reimen und zwar würd ich sagen haben wir
mit dem ersten und zwar ist das rosen
sind rot ich stehe am grab weil mein
geliebter kitchenaid pürierstab hat so
viel langeweile das so sprachen lernen
da das jetzt auf jeden fall das zweite
lustige gedichte dass sich vorbereitet
habe und zwar rosen sind rot so oft in
der sauna dass ich fast schmerzt deshalb
nennt man meinen freund und mich auch
die wellness vor geld ich glaube das
sind wellensittich dass jetzt das
nächste produkt das eine person ebay
kleinanzeigen reingestellt hat und zwar
seht ihr schon dass es ein bild in grün
preis ist 100 euro verhandelbar in der
kategorie bilder und poster allerdings
schreibt da unten dazu tolles bild
welches ich jahrelang genutzt habe wie
nutzt man
ein bild hier verkauft jemand eine
edelstahl mikrowelle und ein interessent
sagt heid 20 euro würde ich nehmen der
verkäufer antwortete daraufhin ok hab
kein auto kommen können sie bin ausheber
keine ahnung was er damit jetzt sagen
wollte allerdings antwortet der
verkäufer hat nein und er interessant
daraufhin arschloch er das war ebay
kleinanzeigen quasi in den nahtstellen
was ebay kleinanzeigen auch eine nation
ist das hier und zwar fragen ob eine
person hallo was ist ihre letzte prise
bitte reicht nicht richtig gute
kastanien und zwei törtchen wird zum
tausch angeboten richtig lecker geil
direkt neben eine richtig gute kastanie
und zwei törtchen ich tauschen gegen
diesen deckel
komm ins geschäft jetzt eine person eine
rot-schwarze hämmerte zwerg wyandotten
hähnchen aus hobby zucht reingestellt
alles klar okay
allerdings schreibt daraufhin auf jeden
fall eine interessante guten abend ich
würde das huhn gerne nehmen könnte das
gut zu mir nach hause laufen wäre das
denn möglich liebe grüße ja kann man
schon erwarten
beim nächsten ebay fair geht es darum
dass eine person ein camouflage t shirt
verkaufen möchte der begriff kmu
beziehungsweise camouflage in der
langfassung kommt ja daher dass es leute
im krieg getragen haben
weil die farben zu grün braun sind sowie
erdboden sowie bäume etc und damit wird
man wenn man das anhalte schwer vom
feind erkannt die person hat das auf
jeden fall hier eingestellt für 500 euro
da denkt man sich ja das muss ja
wirklich ein krankes camouflage ort sein
und die produktbilder sind diese hilfe
[Musik]
ist einfach so camouflage als man ihn
gar nicht mehr gehen als nächstes
verkaufte jemand für drei euro eine rote
baby waschschüssel aus hannover 30 161
mitte
man denkt sich vielleicht wenn man jetzt
ließ der rote baby waschschüssel hey das
ist eben eine kleine badewanne film bbm
ist das hier das das ist die
plastikverpackung von einem lieferdienst
der einen seite
ich dir props aussprechen da für die
kreativ du bist darunter etwa draufkommt
dass man das als baby waschschüssel
verkauft und auf der anderen seite gibt
es locker auf ebay kleinanzeigen auf
solche vollidioten die das glauben und
das ding kaufen das jetzt das nächste
ebay angebot und zwar schon im titel und
im titelbild mein iphone 8 plus also
eine person verkauft anscheinend sein
iphone 8 plus in der beschreibung steht
allerdings hallo das ist mein iphone
dieses nicht zu verkaufen wollte euch
einfach nur mal zeigen dass ich eines
habe glück und hier verkauft jemand eine
tommy hilfiger jogginghose für 70 euro
verhandelbar aus filderstadt und unten
in der beschreibung steht bietet diese
jogginghose zum verkauf hat 920 euro vor
einem jahr gekostet seegurke erhalten
war warum seegurke erhalten bei ist das
oberteil noch zu haben ist leider
momentan reserviert sind sind scheiße
tut mir echt leid meine freundin hat
geweint und ich musste lachen als
ausrede habe ich dann gesagt dass ich
sauer auf eine chrysler in war die mir
nicht das t shirt verkauft hat und
deswegen so etwas geschrieben habe ok
ok
was ebay kleinanzeigen für humor kracher
raushaut ist echt wahnsinn pringles rot
zu verschenken habe fast die ganze dose
gegessen aber jetzt bin ich satt danke
dass du uns darüber informiert
sie lernen sprachen hallo ich
interessiere mich für ihre drei stühle
leider weiß ich nicht ob diese zu
unserem esstisch und den dazugehörigen
stühlen passen wäre es möglich dass ich
mit meinem esstisch und einem stuhl zu
ihnen komme um es einmal probe zu
stellen das wäre sehr nett viele grüße
hallo sie wollen mit ihrem esstisch
vorbeikommen ja also manche leute da
das auch geil ist das hier ein sofa saß
eine person zwei euro allein gestellt
hat in ebay und yahoo kann man nur im
winter drauf sitzen menschen es sind
ziemlich abstoßend dass jetzt der
nächste ebay feld und versucht dort
jemand einen bmw e46 daraufhin bekommt
er bilder geschickt von einer person die
seinen bmw e46 abgeben will daraufhin
schreibt allerdings guten tag das auto
ist mir leider zu groß
mit freundlichen grüßen kann ich
verstehen wenn sie einen 46 suchen dass
ihnen meine 46 zu groß ist das will ich
auch nicht gecheckt das ist so wie wenn
du sagst ich hätte gern apfel eine
person gibt den apfel und sagst
hier seht ihr schon das produkt vom
nächsten die bfl eingeblendet und zwar
ist es eine wii konsole allerdings hat
der typ das irgendwie nicht so richtig
verstanden mit dem lesen und schreibt
wii-konsole hallo ich verkaufe wie ohne
kabel ohne garantie band riffe melden
sie ja
bei gott ich melde mich hier denkt man
sich eigentlich händler verkauft jetzt
irgendein land wird irgendein bauer
keine ahnung was seine was auch immer
das ist ich glaube das kommt einem
mähdrescher oder irgendwie so dran ich
bin jetzt auch nicht so der materie drin
allerdings ist das ein star wars tie
fighter für 100000 euro aus versmold
geil aber darf sich damit einfach zum
mond dann demnächst hier verkauft jemand
auf ebay kleinanzeigen seinen adidas to
be you laschet sneaker daraufhin bekommt
er die nachricht von einem potenziellen
käufer also von einem interessenten 30
euro jetzt ich komme er schickt seine
telefonnummer dazu der verkäufer von dem
adidas tribüne aus schreibt dann
allerdings zehn euro
was
kommt für zehn euro holen daraufhin
schreibt der interessent einen swinger
smiley und fragt bist du dir sicher
oder was hallo
nein warte kurzem ihr schreibt noch
jemand scheiß auf den kommt 55 euro ich
brauche deine adresse höhe
nein nein
lebach hast du ein auto also bist du
über 18 ich brauche das schuhe vw ich
habe auto golf
tauscht die schuhe gegen golf ich meine
wenn ich jemand habs grad und es
trotzdem
alles tut und kommen wir nun auch schon
zum letzten mal fällt für das heutige
video meine lieben freunde es ist
allerdings kein richtiger ebay felson in
einer extrem kreative verhandlungen die
die beiden dort gefühlt haben und zwar
verkauft hat jemand ein pokemon mond in
nintendo 3ds daraufhin schreibt ein
käufer allein in wilder käufer erscheint
verkäufer schickt sich selbst in den
kampf einkäufer setzt verhandlungs basis
ein sehr effektiv käufer sitzt preis
halbierung ein abgewehrt käufer setzt
letzte preis ein sehr effektiv verkäufer
verliert 5 euro an energie verkäufer
setzt abschluss ein
der käufer ist geflüchtet nein spaß
nämlich supervisor eine mischung aus
truck anfang aber sehr lustig beste
verein um die ich je hatte und das finde
ich auch an der stelle werde ich das
heute wieder lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen da würde ich mich selbst
entsetzt darüber einen daumen hoch von
euch unter dem video freund schreibe
gerne in die kommentare was ich bin bin
ich cool oder dumm
fragen über fragen schreibt unten in die
kommentare
abonniert main kanal nein
[Musik]